voilà trouvait dans l'eau sophie ivan
notre spécialiste miel qui sait très
bien décrire les le goût du miel allez
on va parler opéra et opéra en plein air
avec joie ni sa famille ni d'écart
bonsoir vous êtes directrice du pôle
culture à la mairie de buc et pour la
7ème édition du grand le parc du château
de buc samedi soir il y aura un opéra en
plein air
cette année c'est à l'ida de verdi
l'adresse et la traviata
j'ai envie de dire que manon banon
s'était on a rendu hommage à jules
massenet alma nous tous à l'opéra le
plus fan bon la vous avez choisi alain
perrin connu absolue que connaît comment
se fait d'abord se soit dopé les bains
c'est le bicentenaire de verdi alors je
voulais juste dire que c'est le maire
qui devait être là ce soir donc je
m'excuse en son nom alors voilà j'ai
essayé de répondre aux questions
donc effectivement allons vous accueille
avec poule est passé le bicentenaire de
verdi dont compétions rendre hommage
as ferland tué personnages donc voilà on
a choisi aïda effectivement c'est un
opéra ambitieux l'an passé c'est long
c'est assez long quand même trois heures
croisement voilà le dernier tract absolu
sur la distribution sur les artistes
combien d'artistes alors j'ai fait appel
à kehl alors depuis depuis 2007 1 c'est
la date de démarrage de cette belle
aventure qu'est l'opéra c'est un opéra
en plein air qui se passe au château de
buc donc au lieu du patrimoine bucquoy
et nous travaillons toujours avec la
même la même troupe qui s'appelle opéra
classique à et qui a pour spécificité de
tourner sur les lieux historiques donc
en fait l'idée c'est en même temps
d'inviter les gens à venir découvrir un
opéra de grande qualité mais aussi de
découvrir un lieu de faire vibrer un
lieu qui a une très très belle histoire
vous allez me raconter après l'histoire
avec plaisir histoire de lui mais là
c'est le smatah smetana figeant les
moniteurs orchestra de prague l'absolu
officiers parce que je me dis que pour
officier en plein air voilà il faut
faire appel à des professionnels enfin
ça c'est des grands professionnels c'est
un orchestre de grande qualité
le il est mondialement connu justement
mondialement connu et peut-être pour
ceux qui veulent une petite piqûre de
rappel je propose d'écouter un extrait
de l'aïd à de faire 10
extradé vers la matrice de dota
absolument
depuis petit j'ai toujours rêvé de
chanter l'ô plus haut mais voilà et ben
non
bon il sortait évidemment remplacé
carmen ça c'est formidable mais par
contre c'est quelque chose qui me qui
m'épate quand même je me dis pour un
opéra en plein air pour que les voix
puissantes en jeu connu qui est un
travail de technique derrière je ne dise
pas que les chanteurs n'ont pas de voix
parce qu'évidemment on chante le père
ans on a énormément de voix mais pour
que ça puisse se porterait comme ça dans
un parc du château il ya une
sonorisation qui doit être alors une
raison et une petite technique on met en
place des tribunes pour essayer un petit
peu de créer ménard et ils ne sont qu
série effectivement la troupe qui vient
à buc est une troupe de professionnels
donc ils savent pas lié à ce genre de
difficultés c'est facile justement de
trouver des artistes qui acceptent de se
prêter au jeu
le sentais en plein air plutôt que de
chanter dans une sas ce n'est pas simple
ce n'est pas simple c'est vrai que c'est
un choix drastique il ya tout un travail
qui se fait pendant une année avec le
directeur artistique qui choisit bien
ses artistes
il faut dire que cette année on a
énormément de chance c'est ernesto mme
grise à l'est ce qui qui qui prend le
rôle de du thé l'enquêté nord qui prend
le rôle de ramade s est effectivement
c'est un ténor de renommée
internationale et nous sommes vraiment
fiers et ravis de l'accueillir
aïda tout un casting a été fait 80
candidates venues du monde entier
le casting a été fait en allemagne et
c'est une française qui a été choisie
comme isabelle hanche
voilà donc qui est une fille qui a
beaucoup beaucoup de talent et qui s'est
occupé la scène voilà bon toi ça ce sera
donc à découvrir samedi soir c'est lui
manque du château de g2 buccale et on va
faire une petite pause dans cet
entretien nous sommes allés dans les
rues de 50 pour demander les gens s'ils
étaient amateurs d'eau car vous êtes
amatrice d'opéra on va voir si les saint
quentinois amateurs d'opéra et surtout
quel type d'opéra il aime on écoute les
réponses non je suis désolé j'aime pas
un opéra du tout c'est pas quelque chose
qui m'attire
voilà je suis beaucoup plus inefficace
mais je fais quand même si on me l'offre
o'shea v l'opéra j'aime
dans les grandes lignes j'y suis allée
plutôt sur des opérettes mais jamais
fait d'opérer en tant que tel c'est
jamais allé je vais de temps en temps
oui mais j'aime bien l'ambiance et puis
la musique classique et bien j'y suis
allé deux fois par curiosité j'ai bien
aimé j'aime bien l'opéra parce que c'est
agréable c'est de la musique classique
haye avait redit tosca puccini fin plein
plein plein plein ouais j'aime l'opéra
certains opéras et c'est une façon aussi
de chanter comme le rat j'aime beaucoup
l'opéra ça me rappelle tellement de
chose de vieux souvenirs
carmen de bizet voilà c'est ça le
dernier que j'ai vu l'eau place à la
cote de l'histoire et ça raconte celle
là c'est de l'art nous sommes demande
alors le cas ça raconte une histoire
effectivement l'opéra ça raconte une
histoire
quelle est l'histoire d'agde a alors
aidé en fait c'est un opéra qui a été
comment dire commandé par lucky divin du
caire pour l'inauguration pour
l'inauguration du canal de suez et donc
effectivement c'est une histoire triste
1 malheureusement qui se termine mal
puisqu'elle retrouve ramallets sait il
meurt ensemble mais c'est vrai que c'est
une histoire on en fait on montre la
femme elle est déchirée entre son amour
et l'idée de défendre son peuple
donc voilà c'est vraiment un opéra on
n'en ressentent beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotion parce que effectivement c'est
ça finit mal malheureusement mais voilà
alors dans l'est on est on est vraiment
dans les salles d'opéra les opérations
sont titrés mais est-ce que celui
normalement oui oui ça va vous pouvez me
suis très il y aura une voie là il y
aura comme on appelle ça un écran
électronique pour pouvoir parce que
c'est vrai que effectivement l'année
dernière c'était ma non ce qui en
français donc on s'est un peu difficiles
à articuler
mais effectivement à l opéra après il
c'est une gymnastique info suivre en
même temps à lire mais généralement les
gens ils connaissent l'histoire et
qu'ils arrivent à s'y retrouver c'est
vrai qu'il vaut mieux que ce soit sous
titré en tout cas nous on y tient une
question d'organisation
est-ce qu'il ya encore des places
disponibles peu en première série encore
un petit peu en deuxième série mais
voilà combien ça monte alors vous savez
c'est un c'est un opéra qui est porté
par une commune donc qui a pour
politique tarifaire vraiment
l'accessibilité ça vraiment on y tient
beaucoup parce qu'on a on entend souvent
dire que l'opéra est donc nous on essaie
justement d'amener les gens et tout un
travail de fond pour amener les gens à
découvrir cet art et
c'est 35 euros la première série 30
euros la seconde et 20 euros en fait
accordés les études effectivement je
confirme c'est pas cher sur l'opéra et
la de verdi en plus est en plein air
donc c'est vraiment c'est enrichir
beaucoup sur nos partenaires justement
pour arriver à ce travail là c'est à
dire qu'il ya un travail qui est porté
par la cause sinon entièrement la
commune louis et financent entièrement à
la base et donc effectivement il ya la
billetterie à côté mais qui ne couvre
pas mais le effectivement l'idée c'est
vraiment de porter la culture de la
rendre accessible
donc nous avons un autre travail avec
beaucoup de partenaires et de sponsors
qui viennent justement nous aider à
porter cet événement et vous parlez de
partenaires vous aurez un petit mot son
travail que les scolaires
ah oui mais vous avez les scolaires
alors ça on y tient beaucoup vraiment
avec la municipalité en place fait un
gros travail ce que j'appelle le nôtre
triangle de bataille le patrimoine la
culture et l'éducation est en fait à
travers nos événements on cherche à
faire connaître le patrimoine de buc est
une ville riche qui a une histoire riche
et beaucoup de trésors cachés et en même
temps la jeunesse c'est vraiment un
investissement donc effectivement on
essaie d'attirer les jeunes vers 7 à
découvrir cet art lyrique et donc un
énorme travail qui est fait avec les
écoles et même cette année un collège
donc on est ravi l'idée est temps de
travailler en amendant leur projet
pédagogique pour justement seraient
alors retrouvés le soir même sur la
scène donc c'est des figures fait
d'accord je galère sont des figurants
séparé de partenariat merci beaucoup
aimé que ça tu as aimé inscrire merci
venue sur le plateau du 7 8 et donc je
rappelle cet opéra aïda de verdi dans le
parc du château de buc on n'a pas le
temps de raconter l'histoire du juge at
river l'histoire très belle soirée vous
reviendrez nous emparer la digue 9 avril
donc aïda de verdi en plein air et en
plus la météo annonce un temps plutôt
clément un peu nuageux ne sera pas de
pluie donc allez-y c'est dans le parc du
château de buc ce samedi soir